So this is actually incredible. This is
sort of like the height of a complete
disconnect from the real world facts, rationality,
empiricism, common sense, sanity. It's the
opposite of everything that is good.
I'm going to play a video for you
of Trump campaign press communications
director Aaron Pareene going on Fox News.
Towards the end of Donald Trump's hospital
stay for Corona virus. And she says, hey,
Trump now is the better candidate than Biden
because Trump has the firsthand experience of
having the virus. Joe Biden doesn't have that.
In other words, you should vote for Trump because
Trump has the virus. And Joe Biden does not.
She's making the case that you should not vote
Biden because he lacks personal knowledge of
what it's like to have corona virus. And I am
we're gonna play the clip first. This actually
is a much bigger issue of the lack of empathy
that exists on the American right. I don't want to
get ahead of myself. Let's look at the clip first.
So is that something we should expect with a best
case scenario? The president leaves the hospital
today, gets back out on the campaign trail. Will
we see changed messaging when it comes to the
Corona virus? And will it move more to a forefront
of the president's messaging, zinc, key issues?
Well, first hand experience is always going to
change how someone relates to something that's
been happening. The president has corona
virus. Right now, he is battling it head
on as toughly as only President Trump can. And
listen, that of course, that's going to change
the way that he the way that he he speaks of
it because it'll be a firsthand experience.
But, you know, that experience, that
experience of not only Corona virus,
but being president of the United States. That's
why you just see a different tone overall from it.
But it's been like having a first hand experience,
a face sorry, and really sort of law and order.
And it's been the economy. Does this
become a key issue? Is it a virus as well?
He's talked about it all. And listen, he
has experience as commander in chief. He
has experience as a businessman. He has experience
now of fighting the corona virus as an individual.
Those firsthand experiences. Joe
Biden, he doesn't have those. He does.
That's right, guys. Trump now has
experience fighting Corona virus.
On a personal level, Joe Biden does not.
Because Joe Biden has been responsible.
And Donald Trump has not. And it led to Donald
Trump very predictably catching the virus. So
I guess vote Trump over Biden because Trump
has Corona virus. What a loser Joe Biden is.
He can't even catch covered during a global
pandemic. Well, tell this to the families
of the two hundred and fifteen thousand. We
were just like 80 deaths shy a few hours ago
of what will very soon be two hundred and sixteen
thousand deaths due to Corona virus. Say it to
them that Trump is the better choice because
he caught the virus. These are people who will
say anything at all that in the moment they
believe will help get Trump reelected. And now
the real thing I want to talk about here is we've
talked about, you know, are there Trump voters who
might abandon Trump because getting Corona virus
makes him look weak, as silly as that is. Aaron
Pareene is making the opposite argument here,
which is vote Trump because he has Corona virus.
And, you know, what's the logical conclusion to
this? Show your solidarity with Trump by going
out and getting Corona virus yourself. I mean,
it's it's the epitome of a rational thinking.
And they're almost making having the virus
some kind of badge of honor in a sick way. But
the really important thing I want to focus
in on is, you know, we've talked before
about the homophobic Republican politician who
only when their kid or their niece or whatever
comes out do they say, I. I realize I've been
hurting people. I never knew what it would be
like to have someone in my family. It's this
complete inability to empathize with a situation
that is not actually their own. That's sort of the
basis of this argument. Right. If you believe that
the only way to really understand the serious
seriousness of the virus and the urgency of
dealing with it responsibly is to get coronavirus
virus, then maybe you would vote for Donald Trump.
But this is exactly the problem of thinking. We
you know, we hear from the right all the time,
these examples of how they can not empathize
unless they specifically they personally are
affected by something. I'm not worried about
that because I understand that Joe Biden,
much like many people, even without having the
virus. Themselves can understand the urgency of
dealing with it, can understand how highly
contagious it is, can understand the health
implications, the economic implications,
and on and on and on. And then just like
to take this for a second and imagine that it's
a serious comment. Obviously, it's lunacy to say
vote Trump because he caught the virus and Biden
didn't. That's crazy. It's crazy to say that it is
the last gasp of desperation. Hopefully it won't
work. But let's take it seriously for a moment and
imagine for a second that we want to evaluate this
as a serious thing to say. Trump got the virus,
received a helicopter ride. Two top notch health
care from a team of 10 doctors. And who knows how
many nurses and support staff in a six room
medical suite or however many rooms it is.
At Walter Reed Medical Center, Trump still
doesn't have experience receiving the inadequate,
unaffordable health care, while either having
lost your job or having to figure out how can
I survive? Because now I can't work because
I have the virus that has affected so many
Americans. Even the argument that now that
Trump had the virus, he better understands the
experience of Americans. That's also wrong.
Trump, still, despite having Corona virus,
does not understand the typical experience for an
American who either has or is related to someone
who has had serious coronavirus. And again, why
do they need to experience it personally? To
finally have an awakening and understand
it? It's like the anti-gay Republican
who understands their own homophobia once their
kid comes out as gay or their niece comes out as a
lesbian or whatever the case may be. These people
are disgusting and we absolutely must remove them.